the Joe Rogan experience I've been a fan
of yours for a while you I think you're
the last great radio host and you will
be the last famous radios because I
think radio a flying thing you're the
last great one you're the you're the one
who made a famous from radio who the
[ __ ] else yeah
in this era I mean yeah I think radio is
like one of those uh one of those rare
lanes where it's really not a lot of
people who prosper in it yeah you know I
mean like I don't think about especially
in the black radio space I mean you've
got the Tom joiners the Doug banks to
Wendy Williams yeah you know so it's
rare in that Lane but I think I think
you've got people that have established
good careers and yeah that's a great
question when it was the last one he's
the last one you're the last person to
become famous from radio Bobby bones
Bobby bones oh that's nice I don't know
who that is
I'm sure he's great even nationally
syndicated radio but he's on the country
stage he just want to merit you wanna
dance with the Stars oh okay yeah I'm
not I don't give somebody only know
Bobby be as you talk about really yeah
yeah he's got two national New York
Times bestselling books season that's
one of those things though it's like
comedians like you know used to talk
about a comic that everybody loves and
people like I've never heard of like
amongst comics she's expected yeah Bobby
host on Idol now okay yeah then we're on
the same age so I would have to give it
I would have to put him in that you and
Bob you're a gracious man yeah in my
opinion you're the Last Samurai guys
like you I just want to snatch you up
and bring you over to podcast like get
the [ __ ] out of there
get out of that censored bossman world
the hell with interesting guys I know
podcast together the brilliant idiot you
know we don't you know pod track right
you know yeah sure sure like we just
cracked five track The Breakfast Club
he's number 20 on patre okay so you put
that online as well yeah we put it out
of the park that's good I feel like
we're radio that's what it is like
people still listening to terrestrial
radio black you have to go where the
people are so you have to have the
podcast you have to have the YouTube
following like you can't wait for people
just to come to radio ever I wish I
could swear though so that's the
probation that's the thing he city they
release all the interviews they
on Breakfast Club and those things
explode yeah you too and they have all
the curse exactly that's where most
people globally yeah would watch and
listen I mean right yeah that's what
separates this radio this arrow of radio
from other eras of radio like Howard
Stern didn't have YouTube you know
saying if I was third at YouTube we
wouldn't be no question he'd still be
the [ __ ] guy me even though he
is the guy right but he'd still be like
super super the guy in this air ride
he's in that paywall which is very
strange a serious paywall that's the
strangest paywall yeah yeah he took the
check but then you get financial
independence back why is it recheck
let's be realistic
he's already financially independent so
I didn't do it I just the numbers
they're thrown at him yeah that was a
difference three hundred million right
well I think that was just initially it
I think he makes like a hundred million
every year something crazy like three
hundred was flat and then another
hundred what stars I got the differ
between like your kids beings creating
like your great great great grandkids
beings great right yeah but serious
stock it serious this means like
blockbuster stock I remember when
Netflix used to have those DVDs that you
would get like in front of the [ __ ] it's
the right mafia the right like you have
to send it back now I was so funny I was
home this weekend I was in Montana South
Carolina
and like there was a Black Panther DVD
from the library in my mom's house I'm
like what yeah it's like Panthers in the
original Black Panthers or I was like oh
she was true from back in the day that's
an original black got the Black Panther
DVD that they checked out from the
library and have not bought it back yet
you can bring it back to the library
yeah now you don't have to like what are
they really gonna do why Maddie the
Black Panther from the library cuz even
wanted it and it was there and you were
at the library I'm still trying to
understand why you called library what
is it library I don't [ __ ] know I
didn't graduate got it there it's like
library yeah it's one of those words
yeah you know
actually yeah but everyone even like
George Bush when he was president would
say expecially yeah yeah yeah I think a
lot of it have to do a reason because I
still say straight streets wrong okay
yeah pronouncing screech screech bro I
get it scrumptious pacifically specific
specifically specifically yeah everybody
knows then it's fun that's the point if
you had a person saying I can wrap them
right it's a way to dick but it's like
dialects like my grandparents were from
Sicily and they would talk in dialects
and even people that new Italian
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] they're
saying yeah like just like people that
knew pure Italian it's some weird like
Pig Latin type [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
my mom's Scottish like if you listen to
real Scottish people talk you don't
understand what the [ __ ] they're talking
oh that with that accent so stirred the
way they roll their words together thick
and then they get them drunk oh it's
impossible
[Applause]